tutti ragazzi il benvenuto questo video
sono parigi
oggi siamo tornati dopo dopo anni cioè
non mi ricorda anche più l'ultima volta
che ci ho giocato siamo tornati su gap
simulator ragazzi che quel simulatore di
capre che vi ricorderete per bene tutti
quanti perché è uscito un dlc
praticamente unisce top simulator a pay
day non so se partiamo non so neanche
come tod's tra i delfini di sony delfini
questa cosa va bene stay calm stai calma
lo dici a tua sorella prima cosa fosse
successo forse non ho capito non ho
capito cosa devo fare
un che pay day un gioco di rapine prima
di tutto quindi dovrei rapinare una
banca con il mio fido destriero non
potete incarcerare una che un ariete
perché io sono dell'ariete tra l'altro
quindi posso incornare la gente tipo
così vero zia bella presse tab 2 to
switch crew member posso cambiare ai
membri della ma che cazzo è un delfino
psg per equipaggiare la maschera perde
fino a che è possibile e trova una b e
ea machine accusa la devo rapinare un
bancomat ma sono un cazzo di delfino
sulla sedia rotelle è un incrocio tra
non c'è chi cazzo succede o merda o
liberato è uno stupro che cazzo succede
a zia e mi aiuti e non svelo niente se
non altro ragazzi abbiamo sbloccato la
il fenicottero che mi sembra il più
sveglio di tutti quanti ve lo zio vami
capire oddio mica velocissimo ma posso
controllare nella mente le persone
[Musica]
mi spieghi cosa mischia barnabè non mi
importa
non voglio sapere un morto bene credo
che ti chiamerò e george ciao george
salute edward george bravo edwards mi
senti mili beri grazie
nel cast azionati non vorrei volevo
andare via in teoria l'obiettivo di
questo gioco in teoria è quello di
rapinare il bancomat
eccolo eccolo trovato ho trovato
perfetto posso rapina aspetta aspetta
prima devo mettere la maschera che se
non mi riconoscono che cazzo serafino
sono ecco adesso sei brent select più
gere
ma come va auguri di posso cambiarle ma
alla maschera sulla maschera geniale una
solida sicilia son compriamo ma ho
comprato la maschera da qui la così
nessuno potrà di conoscerli fantastico
facendo ciò che lei factory facciamo se
madonna troppa roba enormi sì ma sta
mappa quindi dobbiamo andare a rapinare
la chop tale chocolate 7 questa qui sta
camminando su un palo
beh io vado a caso cioè non me ne frega
niente nega cos'è
c'è un coso qui bello ho sempre
desiderato fare questo nella mia vita
perfetto o cristo chi sono attaccato che
non avete visto niente ragazzi come
faccio a rami chiave stile non si è
mossa di un millimetro favola pool a la
plata tanto non mi può riconoscere cioè
la maschera delfino su cup
questo era gratis credo fortemente che
sia fatta meglio questa che la mappa di
dvd costi momento è quella di prima ciao
zio a posto sì stanco di lavorare niente
sei morto pazienza
scusa non lo giuro che non volevo vendo
cose sicuramente non rubate va bene mi
fai vedere cosa non hai rubato e poi c'è
questa cosa che credo sia un credo abbia
lo stesso cos'è oddio adesso si è
diventato una borsa con una borsa ciao
gatto sono una borsa ti sei preso paura
che brucia la borsa e non lo sapete voi
ma io sto cazzo non c'è più rispetto per
le borse bastardi e iban sono una borsa
e so che tu mi vuoi non far finta niente
so che mi vuoi spende i soldi comprano
comprami tu mi vuoi troppo shopping fa
ma le ragazze non avrà mai detto nessuno
esce mai stuprato una donna ti ho visto
chiamerò la polizia hanno 6 la polizia e
vabbé brutti i corrotti del cazzo morite
io e il mio [ __ ] idrante
conquisteremo il mondo ragazzi in realtà
noi siamo dai tutti molestano donne in
questo gioco
bravo tu si che sai come fare innamorare
una bella città si prevde al cazzo
faccio io no no no vieni qua di nico a
guardà facciamo i palleggi facciamo i
palleggi della spiaggia o un'amica che è
una borsa tela porto certe la presento
non le piacciono l'unica donna al mondo
che non le piace alle borse è morto cosa
vuoi da solo scherzavo accettino anche
allo sgabello ti sta inserendo sul
niente
ora vinci amici mitchell apc comunque
ragazzi lavici la volevo usare col
fenicottero io non hanno sbagliato
salvagente tutto a posto lei guardi per
niente di strano ravece sulle strisce
sulle strisce non può attraversare su
era suo ma cosa vuoi una sedia che lì
perché sei seduto dentro non lo voglio
sapere dove facciano finita lì siamo
arrivati ragazzi nel punto seta
chocolate bang on fire and put it on the
doors e posso solo dare seriamente
ragazzi devono andare a fuoco per come
facciamo andare a fuoco starò la scusi
devo prendere una di queste cose che
devo mandare a fuoco
devo mandare a fuoco stacco ma perché e
cosa che cosa me ne faccio se vuoi
mangiare zio
l'unica che sgambetto cosa devo fare but
it on the doors e quindi questa porta
qui perfetto quindi chi esce dalla porta
che chi è
anzi non c'è un coso infuocato non si
vabbè se qualcuno avesse le domande sud
perché il gop simulator e così insensato
tipo perché una cazzo di jeep sta
salendo su un altra cazzo di gip era la
mia macchina e non importunare i pali
della luce polizia lo fermi ma cosa fa
ecco se incontra sulla polizia mosca
situano cosa vuoi anzi io sono andato a
parte cosa vuoi cosa vuoi ma se ne sa
chi fast and furious
cosa vuole questo è lui che devi
prendere [ __ ] cosa vuoi qualche c'è
il maggiolino di elevate l'arcano e c'è
un maggiolino qui per me lo voglio lo
voglio
è uno stupro di maggiolino cosa posso
usare un camion
no no no no scherza eccole
non so guidare ragazzi non c'e la
patente c'è qualche problema che se
riesco voglio e mi piace che escono
proprio dallo schermo non è cosa state
facendo
prendo sia la musica a fare questo
effetto io ho trovato dei fiori volevo
rimorchiare la tipa coi fiori invece va
bene ti rimorchio gol cassonetti
dell'immondizia ti piace non le è
piaciuto manco per il cac lockwood che
non saperlo perché questo non riesce a
scavalcare una cazzo di madonna è
possibile cosa come ho fatto a far
capottare una macchina portate tutte le
cose di valore qua dentro
ha voglia si è anzi ecco perche salve
sono un cliente volevo sapere cosa cosa
vendete sono un cliente salve giorno mi
scusi lei che ci sta girando metterebbe
una mano per colpire
ecco perfetta continua a svenire sulla
panchina
io non ho parole ragazza più ridicola
dice veramente assurdo canestro fatto io
niente non ho sfondato neanche una porta
c'è inutile ce la posso fare entrare non
è difficile
sì sì fatto chi cazzo sei tu cosa vuoi
no non mi buttare ma [ __ ] riuscita
ma da zio diventati romani nel ex 26
servirebbe sapere dove tenete gli
oggetti quelli preziosi a posto ho
trovato devo trovare qualcosa
oddio posso trivellare seriamente vai
vai vai vai vai c'è un ascia la pazienza
e mi sembra prima questa professore a
lascia le khadr il con un coldrin non so
bene con questo coso come io possa
scardinare tre anche i tifosi 321 patria
a si è che palle un altro volo trova un
altro thriller va beh ma zio servirebbe
un thriller ragazzi che non ho però va
bene se troviamo un brilla via c'è un
materassino sotto c'è sempre caso grillo
non è cosa che sta roba guardato
cazzotto da buttare giuseppe gallo
centro lo centrano centro concentrato
cioè ragazzi ma cosa c'entra poco con il
simbolo del centro pokémon su
quell'edificio lì che non ho ben capito
che cos'è però ci arrivò in volo perché
io sono un ariete che sa volare perché
protesti su un tetto dio non si regge
niente
cosa stai facendo perché stai pregando
in ginocchio con dei gatti devo salvare
i gatti devo salvare i gatti tutti fuori
è un pazzo maniaco dio
quello è un gatto sono i gatti più
elastici che abbia mai visto ragazzi
complimenti ma che bello arriva bravo si
sa lo zio corrie ragazzi non sono
riusciti a trovare una mazza di thrill
robe del genere pazienza però è stato
figo tra l'altro stato veramente figo
antivirale prossimo episodio perché ci
sono un miliardo e mezzo di cose da fare
quindi va bene
fatemi sapere se vi piace come come
espansione tra tutte quelle che sono
uscite mi sembra per adesso la migliore
c'è troppa ragazzi fatelo sapere cosa
sai cosa vita questo argomento è un mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook e
come nei video tratte descrizione su
sensi discutere ci vediamo al prossimo
video delle ragazze